need motivation you better watch a top
10 we believe nation hey it's evan
carmichael and i make these videos
because you are probably the most
ambitious person in your circle but you
know you're capable of more and you get
that push by surrounding yourself with
the best so today let's learn from one
of the best mel robbins and my take on
her top 50 rules for success
enjoy
i think that the work that we all have
to do
every single one of us whether you
bulldoze
whether you people please
whether you avoid conflict
whether you're impulsive
whether you uh yo-yo your decisions
uh
whatever it is that is your pattern
you know you the the constant trashing
yourself
i think the the the journey of your
whole life
is figuring out how to truly
like
and love yourself
if you
are afraid of disappointing people
if you're afraid that you're not good
enough
you may catch that in one area of your
life but as your life gets bigger and as
you change it'll creep in in other areas
and one way that those patterns where
you don't think you deserve it or you
don't think you're good enough or you're
terrified of disappointing people
comes into play is when you start to
expect the worst
and so
catch it that's the first step you can't
break your pattern unless you see it
and then you're gonna replace it and
what i'm gonna start doing is i've got
this little app on my watch you can set
it on your phone
where
every like three hours it reminds me to
breathe and i notice the second that the
alarm goes off i've been holding my
breath
and so you can set a little alarm in
your phone megan's laughing you can set
a little alarm in your phone that just
says saver it's a reminder to take a
minute you can make it say take a minute
take a minute look around comp your
compliment yourself on what's going
right because
expecting the worst is something you
taught yourself to do guess what you can
teach yourself to take a minute
and to savor what's going right and the
more you force yourself to do it the
more it'll become a habit it comes back
to the core message that i always have
for you no matter what's happening
around or to you you hold the power
because you always have the power to
have an honest conversation you always
have the power to discuss how things are
impacting you you always have the power
to make requests and you certainly have
the power to draw boundaries and you
also have the power by the way if the
culture gets worse and worse or you just
are tired of it because it's not
changing to go find a different job
the power is always in you and i think
that's something that's so important to
constantly remind yourself i get that i
don't like where i am but what could i
do to change it
how can i change how i think about this
and i'm telling you right now you know
this the second you start changing how
you think about a situation the
situation changes the second you start
changing how you think about what your
options are you start to see them the
second you stop thinking that you're
stuck or that you're a victim and you
start thinking about how you solve
something you start to see solutions and
so the answer is always in you if you
look at human development we're the only
species that literally can't survive
without another human being taking care
of you and so we are biologically
hard-wired to bond with other people and
that is the ver from the very beginning
of when you come out
bonding with somebody else and making
sure they pay attention to you is your
survival imperative so you are born
needing somebody else and i think what
ends up happening is there's never that
kind of clean
break or pass off between
needing your parents to take care of you
needing your friends approval to fit in
to truly having ownership over giving
yourself what you didn't get giving
yourself what you needed and that's the
piece that i've been doing a lot of
during the the great pause is slowing
down because so much of my busyness
was fueled by uh you know praise me love
me am i doing enough you know please
tell me i'm doing okay okay i can
breathe now i'm okay now
and when i slow down and maybe it's a
function of the anxiety that's when
things get scary because that's when
you've really got to be with yourself
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there
the reason why it's so important to
start with a friend cleanse and i'm sure
a lot of you how many of you heard that
and you thought oh my god getting rid of
people oh boy oh boy i'm gonna cleanse
these friends
yes and no
a friend cleanse is critical because the
single most influential thing around you
are the people that you hang out with
and if you have relationships
that are toxic if you have relationships
that cause guilt if you have
relationships that are creating drama in
your life if you have relationships that
are not equitable guess what
that's creating the overwhelm that's
creating unhappiness that's
keeping you doubting yourself if you
have friends that um have bad habits
guess what that's making it really
really hard for you to change your
habits for the good you have this
behavior pattern where you snap you have
this behavior pattern where you yell and
you get upset and you make people wrong
and you don't mean to
if you
are somebody who's ever said to yourself
i wish i could stop yelling or i wish i
i i i i could just snap i could stop
snapping
this video is absolutely unbelievable
okay and the reason why is i explain
this research that was so
mind-blowing for me
it's called ghosts in the nursery
a lot of the patterns that you have
that you don't have control over
are patterns from your childhood
and they are
there because when you were a kid
you experienced people in your life that
were tense
did you ever have a parent that was a
yeller did you ever have a teacher that
was a yeller or a coach that was a
yeller and secretly in your little kid
body whenever your mom or dad would yell
or your coach would yell or your teacher
would yell or your grandmother or
grandfather would yell you would feel
tense right
you would feel nervous you would feel on
edge of course that's how we all feel
right well here's the reason why
you might have an issue like i used to
have an issue where i would yell at my
kids and then i'd feel terrible about it
i'd snap at my husband and then i'd feel
terrible about it psychologist and then
i would say to myself i'm not doing that
again i'm not doing that again but i
wouldn't have the ability to end it
psychologists call this ghost in the
nursery
it means that any situation where you
start to feel
tense or you start to feel stressed out
guess what happens your body remembers
what it was like when you were little to
feel tense and stressed out and what
were the adults doing around you when
you felt that way
they were snapping
they were yelling and now here you are
repeating the pattern
and you don't know why
and you feel guilty and i'm explaining
this to you because it wasn't until i
thought holy cow like i know i don't
want to snap at my husband i know i
don't want to take my anger from work
out on my family
why can't i stop this
that's the reason why it's because it's
a pattern that you remember from being a
kid that the adults around you were
snapping or yelling or being mean
any time and when they were you felt
tense and stressed out so now that
you're an adult when you're tense and
stressed out you repeat the behavior
that you witnessed crazy right so how do
you stop it well the first step to
stopping anything is to actually
understand what you're dealing with
now that you know you're dealing with a
pattern
now all you need to do is basically say
okay i'm going to put a practice in
place that's going to interrupt this
pattern what's the practice well a
really good one is
[Music]
before you walk in the house at the end
of the day if you're stressed out take
five
take five deep breaths
like reset your mood reset your energy
before you walk in the house and you'll
be surprised by how much nicer you are
to the people around you
another thing that um that uh
you can do and this one's not so fun is
you can train your
partner your kids your roommates your
family that if you're trying to get a
hold of how you bring stress home you
can train them to say to you hey
don't take your work stress out on me
when somebody that you care about says
that to you it's a humbling experience
and the person that says it the most in
my life is my son oakley your uh the
youngsters seem to love to cross-check
the adults so be careful with taking
that advice i know
that in this next chapter that i
consciously create i want to have more
fun
i wanna i really wanna love the process
yeah i don't want to make it so hard on
myself and be gripping everything so
tight
and it's really easy for me to see it in
other people because i know what it
feels like in here i'm working hard to
break the patterns that still hold me
back and the big one that holds me back
is um bulldozing that's the it's it's
it's literally when i start to feel
any level of tension this is
particularly true in my marriage
um i'm married to a saint thank god
chris robbins meditates every morning
it's the only reason why we've lasted 26
years um it's how he puts up with me
when i feel
my like whatever emotion rise i
immediately raise my voice
it's how i assert power in the
relationship
and i am so committed louis
to
breaking that pattern wow and being a
more fun person to be around and a
kinder person to be around first of all
stop talking about passion
stop talking about launching a business
okay
when you think about it too big it will
paralyze you
if you're lucky and you're in a position
where
your bills are getting paid
and you have the luxury of being able to
try to think about what you want to do
in this next chapter
here's where i want you to start
i want you to start with what energizes
you now how ironic is that given that
i'm speaking at the energetic women's
conference here in indianapolis today
why am i saying energizes you and what
do i talk what am i talking about when i
say energize
when i say energizes you
i'm asking you what is it that you're
curious about
what is it that you feel so
expanded you feel energized you feel
kind of excited whenever you're doing it
you're in a phase when you're just
trying to figure out what's your next
move of just paying attention to your
curiosity paying attention to the things
that interest you the truth is
passion is just energy
if you're passionate about something it
means you're energized when you do it so
let's reverse engineer this and let's
just
ask yourself a simple question
what are you curious about what
energizes you and if you allow yourself
to explore things that energize you
you my friend will start to
find the clues about what it is that you
should and could be doing because all
the research says that if you're doing
something that you like if you're doing
something that you're curious about
you're not only going to enjoy it you're
going to be really good at it because if
you like doing it you'll spend more time
doing it which means you're going to get
better at it sometimes when the dream is
so big
the fact that it's so big becomes
paralyzing
because you think about where you are
right now and you think holy cow that
thing that i really want
i don't even like how do you even start
when the dream is so big so here's what
we're going to do today we're going to
shrink it down because you know me i am
all about simplicity i'm all about
making sure that the advice works for
you because if it doesn't work for you
you're not going to do it and i'm all
about switching how you think about
things making this smaller
and making it something that i'm
learning about rather than doing and
launching and
that somehow thinking about it
differently frees up the ability to get
started if i get you to start doing that
and you do this every day for 10 or 15
minutes which you absolutely can guess
what's going to happen
you're going to feel momentum you're
going to feel like you're working on it
you're going to meet people that are
interested in it you're going to learn
things that are going to lead to the
next thing that you need to learn and
you will have mastered the art of
getting started and by doing something a
little bit every day you're also going
to master the art of continuing to keep
going and from there it'll snowball i
promise you i promise you you see you're
only ever running against yourself
there's room for all of us there's room
for you to do the same thing there's
room for you to write that book there's
room for you to do those makeup
tutorials there's room for you to launch
that restaurant there's room for you to
start your singing lessons there's room
for you to write that song it is normal
and it is going to happen to you all the
time that you're going to see people
that seem to block out the sun whenever
they make an announcement because
they're that big and that amazing i
don't want you to allow yourself to
shrink when somebody else is doing
something that is
similar to what you want to do you
remember that thing we used to do as
kids where you go
um actually you can give yourself
affection i think you know how i have
this habit i have this habit of always
high-fiving myself in the mirror i send
myself into the day go get a mel
that's a form of affection you can show
yourself love through words and through
gifts and through actions because love
is a verb and that's the most important
thing to think about when you think
about practicing
self-love and developing habits around
self-love
so love is a verb
what are the actions and habits and
thoughts that you would have
when you think about how you treat or
speak to somebody you love self-love is
about giving yourself all the things
that you freely give to the people that
you love
and what's so awesome is that when you
learn and start practicing
how to love yourself it expands your
capacity to love other people more
deeply because you can't give other
people
something that you don't give to
yourself and i know you're like whoa i
love other people but you don't truly
love other people if you can't love
yourself
because there's a part of you that
doesn't feel worthy and so you got to
practice this stuff and it's everything
here are some ways that i practice first
of all if
someone you loved were struggling
what would you recommend they do in
terms of how they take care of
themselves first of all you got to get a
good night's sleep that's a form of
self-love
put good food in your body that's a form
of self-love
take time for yourself every day that's
a form of self-love moving your body and
exercising that's a form of self-love
the biggest form of self-love for me
is not criticizing myself so when i
catch myself criticizing myself trashing
myself beating myself up i kick
that
noise and garbage out of my head
and i replace it with something that i
would say to somebody that i love
instead of focusing on the things that
are going wrong i kick that thought out
of my mind and i focus on the things
that are going right
another form of self-love for me is i'm
constantly
soothing and reassuring myself
mel
hey i know it's challenging right now
but this is preparing you for something
mel i know you're nervous but um
you got this
you can face this and notice i'm using
my name mel
study after study has come out that when
you talk to yourself and use your own
name
it has a much deeper impact on you you
have the experience of almost having
someone else be saying it it lands
deeper and it's also through gifts i
also give myself the gift of buying
flowers every time i go to the grocery
store i started doing that a few years
ago
i love flowers i was always waiting for
somebody else to give them to me and it
dawned on me why the hell don't i just
buy it for myself
and so i do and you'd be surprised
three four five bucks you can always
find a small little bouquet at a grocery
store stick it on your desk it's a
reminder
that you love yourself remember love is
a verb just treat yourself how you would
treat somebody that you love and
practice it and you'll get better and
better at it i am in the middle of um
working on my next book it's called the
high five habit
i
believe
with all of my heart and being that
every man woman child person grandparent
everybody
should
infuse their days with habits of
celebration and self-confidence
and the fastest and easiest and most
science-backed way
to
quickly start to change how you see
yourself
is by adopting a simple habit of
high-fiving your reflection in the
mirror every single morning
now i know exactly what you're thinking
are you serious mel robbins that is the
stupidest thing i've ever heard in my
entire life
i know
i know i know it sounds dumb
but the reason why your first instinct
when you think about waking up whether
you're in your robe or your underwear or
your pjs or your birthday suit and
walking into that bathroom and having a
moment with yourself and raising your
hand and high-fiving yourself is because
your self-confidence is in the gutter
you believe some garbage about yourself
you think you're a bad person or you're
unworthy or you're ugly or nobody likes
you or how about this one this was the
story of my life i have [ __ ] up my
life
so badly
i might as well just flush it down the
toilet
you have some narrative in your mind
that is so negative that when you look
in the mirror you see somebody worth
trashing
you see what's wrong you pick apart your
appearance and i want to reverse that
because here's the deal about
self-confidence
self-confidence
begins with you
you
realize the word self is in there right
i can't give you confidence i can give
you a little boost i can give you tools
i can
encourage you
but confidence is forged in fire
it's something that's within you and
here's the thing i want you to realize
about confidence
you are a confident person
that's why you miss feeling that way you
can only miss what you know
you've just been blocked from the
feeling of it
and wherever you are right now in your
life i'm telling you confidence is in
there you just gotta figure out how to
tap into it and you've been building
confidence all along by the way every
time that you have fallen on your face
or you've tried something and failed or
you've gone out and thought you found
the love of your life and then your
heart's broken and then you pick
yourself up again and then you dust
yourself you're building confidence the
entire time because confidence is not
built on the high days confidence is
built on the low ones confidence is
built when you are struggling because
when you see yourself go for something
and fall when you see yourself try and
get knocked down when you see yourself
stand back up after getting abused or
traumatized or discriminated against and
moving ahead you are building
this reserve within yourself where you
know you can rely on yourself you know
you can face hard things and you can
keep moving forward you know you have
your own back so it's in there your life
has been helping you build it now you've
got to just dig in and tap into it and
use it to shut that critic up in your
head
so the way you're going to do that is
every morning i'm not kidding you're
going to raise your hand in the mirror
and high-five yourself look at how many
people are doing this
you're not the only one for five
mornings in a row i want you to high
five yourself
and when you do this i want you to use
the hashtag
high five challenge you know what's
happening when you raise your hand up in
the mirror
you are taking the lifetime positive
association that you have with cheering
for other people believing in other
people
uh celebrating other people
saying let's go to other people
and you are marrying that positive
association
with your reflection we are pulling into
boston college for our daughter's
graduation from college it feels like
we just dropped her off here four years
ago
a week ago
it is insane how fast time goes isn't it
chris it is
almost disturbing it's disturbing and so
i always get really weepy and emotional
on big milestone days
because you become so present to how
quickly your life is passing you by
and the only advice that i have for
myself or anybody else in this moment is
just be
in it
be present for it all
the ups the downs every day
just be in it
um
because you are going to blink your eyes
and
[Music]
your life's going to be over i mean
literally i don't mean to be like morose
about it but it's true and we
spend so much energy wishing things
would pass wishing that something would
be over wishing that
this moment would change and i'm telling
you right now your life is the greatest
school you will ever attend
every day is uh teaching you something
every day is a lesson
and uh the lesson right now is that we
should have showed up earlier because
the traffic is very big
for years when i felt stressed out
when i felt overwhelmed when i started
to feel
burnt out
i would literally react to the feeling
of being stressed and overwhelmed
by stepping on the accelerator i used to
believe that i just if i just ran faster
if i just moved quickly
i would be able to
outrun the overwhelm that i was feeling
and what i have found time and time and
time again
is that you cannot gain control by
speeding up
the way that you gain control of
anything in life is by slowing down and
whenever i feel like my own life is like
that car where the wheel's shaking and
i'm going and i feel like i'm going to
lose control and my instinct is to step
on the gas and go go go
i have taught myself in those moments to
stop
get off social media
cancel meetings
take a couple personal days
put your phone away
get out in nature if you can
take a deep breath
start your morning slowly
because it's in those moments where you
slow everything down that you
really
gain control again because you start to
get located in your body bottom line if
you feel overwhelmed
do what i did
do not
step on the accelerator
take the off ramp
slow down take a day off
you will learn when you take your foot
off the gas and you allow yourself to
coast to a stop
that
the world will go on
you need a break and when you stop
racing around and running and dealing
with the stress and
you will literally
see in the calm what the path forward is
i wanted to make this video because i
know in some area of your life you are
wanting to start something you're
wanting to put yourself out there more
and you are holding yourself back and
one place that i see this playing out
all the time is the fact that so many
people probably you
are self-conscious and nervous about
putting videos online you're
self-conscious and nervous about talking
about your business or sharing the
breakthroughs that you're having or just
showing up in a bigger bolder more
self-express way because heck it makes
your life more fun when you do and so
you have this deep yearning to be doing
more and then i know exactly what
happens to you you look at the number of
people that follow you
you then say who the hell am i to say
that you then go nobody's going to watch
it anyway and i want to share with you
brand new research that blows that lame
excuse although normal excuse right out
of the water it was published literally
this month from ohio state university
and it proves that when it comes to
video content
the video content that people find
compelling
has nothing to do with the number of
views that it has it has to do
with the
person and the message that's being
communicated to be compelling to make an
impact to be influential because i know
everybody wants to raise their influence
and their visibility and to show up in
bigger ways
it is all about the message
and you're in control of that
do you communicate with passion do you
have conviction about what you're
talking about you could be talking about
oh i don't know
uh whether you like white cords or these
like black cords with this end or
whether you like this kind of end or
this end or where you like this cap or
whether you oh i love to drink this way
because i have a big nose and then this
way
and i'm telling you you don't have to
have this thing on you could literally
talk about anything and if you bring
passion and you bring conviction to what
you're talking about
people will pay attention
that's what real influence is it's the
ability to show up in ways and have
conviction and passion about the things
that you believe in whether you're
talking about a water bottle cap or
you're talking about how to be healthier
happier or more effective in your life
so enough with the excuses enough with
worrying about how many followers you
have or whether or not aunt sue is gonna
like the video or not or what people are
gonna think
the only thing that matters is the
conviction and passion
that you communicate with and of course
getting started so based on the research
get started put that video out you gotta
be honest with yourself
if there are things about your
appearance that are within your control
whether it is the shape that you're in
whether it's the health choices that
you're making whether it's how you take
care of yourself in terms of self-love
and you're not
taking action in those areas
the lack of action says to your brain
you don't care about yourself and so
what i want you to do is pick one thing
one behavior that you could do every day
the high fives one of them pick another
one and i want you to practice doing it
and it's a behavior if you think about
the person that you want to become
what's that person do every day that you
don't do right now
and when you start to do the thing that
the person you want to become is doing
you leverage something called behavioral
activation therapy
and that is a whole body of research
that says when you act like the person
you want to become it's the most
powerful way to change a habit
it's even uh better therapy than uh
talk therapy because the action proves
to your brain that you're becoming that
person you're seeing the change through
the action and so then the brain catches
up and starts to relate to you like a
person that's confident or a person who
adores their appearance or a person that
celebrates themselves exactly as they
are we moved to vermont i got a brand
new uh primary care doctor
and i thought he said something really
interesting he's this great guy um he's
settled here because his wife's family
is from vermont and so he's now lived
here for 40 years and at the end of my
uh
first appointment with him
he said a really interesting thing to me
he kind of chuckled because of course
i'm very entertaining and bubbly and all
this stuff and he said it's going to be
really fun to watch what happens to you
and i'm like
what doctor says that to somebody
and i said what do you mean and he said
well i'll tell you mel
in the
years that i've been practicing as a
primary care doctor in southern vermont
i have seen
so many people move to vermont
they're seeking a quieter lifestyle
they're seeking
a change a new chapter
and what i find is
if you what you're actually seeking
is a safe haven
and you're running away from your
problems
a funny thing happens
your problems always go with you
and when you move somewhere very quiet
the solitude just magnifies that that
you were trying to get away from
and so if you're starting a new chapter
because you're excited
and you're
reinventing yourself that's fabulous
still take time to complete the last
chapter that you were in so you step
into the new chapter with all of the
wisdom and the gratitude and the
learning and the growth that you gained
if you are starting a new chapter as so
many of us do because we are running
away from the old us we're running away
from a bad relationship we're closing
the door on something that wasn't
working
you better make sure you take the time
to think through and journal about this
last chapter
who you've been the habits you no longer
want to repeat the mistakes that you
made what you've learned what you're
running from and more importantly what
changes you're going to make and how
this new chapter is going to support you
in doing it and in becoming the person
that you're meant to be
without that intentional moment of
reflection and without that intentional
moment where you're going to list out
the behaviors and thinking patterns and
habits you're changing
my doctor's right
you're just going to take all that crap
you're running from right into this new
chapter i think i am um
engaged in emotional eating right now
uh it is 2
22 in the afternoon
um the wheels are off today um i know
why the reason why is because i did not
stick to my normal routine and i've
noticed since i did not stick to my
routine my day has sort of slid off the
rails in terms of the decisions that i'm
making
um
it's really random like i
had
my son's chicken nuggets for lunch and
there's half an apple that i ate i have
not finished the amount of water i
normally drink it's 2 23 and
i made myself an ice cream sundae
because you know why the hell not
and so as i'm sitting here
enjoying my ice cream sundae i just
thought to myself god
am i emotionally eating right now
oh my god this is so good if i really
unpack what i'm feeling right now
it's raining it's freezing i am
mentally in a creative block
and i'm gonna get this tool that we use
on the mel robin show out i call it the
word wheel so i'm gonna show you the
word wheel right now
here's how you use a word wheel the
average person can only name three
emotions happy sad and angry
but our emotions are actually much
deeper and more complex
and the secret to getting unstuck or
untriggered or freed up in any situation
is to find the words that describe what
you are truly feeling so i'm going to
start with the core emotion of anger and
fear and work out from there
and so as i look at the word wheel
i feel inadequate as a writer
i feel worried
that i'm not going to have a creative
breakthrough
i feel helpless the big one is i feel
inadequate as a writer
whoa big breakthrough
i am
feeding
my inadequacy with an ice cream sundae
you know what's interesting
is simply finding the word
that i feel inadequate as a writer and
that makes me feel afraid
that the book isn't going to be good
that it's not going to be as good as i
want it's not going to do as well it's
not going to get any
accolades or good reviews it's not going
to make a difference in your life as you
identify the feeling and for me it's
inadequate that sunday doesn't taste
very good anymore
because it wasn't a sunday
that i was craving
it was reassurance and comfort from this
deeper feeling that i was feeling
wow that's powerful stuff
really powerful stuff
so if you
are at a moment where you catch yourself
emotionally eating
or you just feel untethered or numb pull
out the word wheel you can find it at
melrose.com
and um i think you'll find it to be a
really incredible tool
that will
help you locate what you're truly
working through and instead of reaching
for
an ice cream sundae which honestly is
going to now tank my mood because of all
the sugar and make me feel uh lethargic
if you can identify the word which for
me is inadequate
inferior worried
frustrated
you can let those feelings rise up move
through them
and then move on
two hours later and let me tell you the
impact of having fed my feelings first
of all i am totally
bloated
so
uh i realize that that's not big but you
know for me
my stomach is just like oh
because all that sugar and
dairy that i just pounded down is now
sitting here like a rock
and this is the problem with emotional
eating because you get caught in this
cycle where you feed these feelings and
then your body starts to tank and your
mood tanks and your stomach gets bloated
and so then you start to make yourself
wrong and feel ashamed
and feel like a bad person because you
did it
[Music]
so how do you stop emotional eating
and what business do i have giving any
of us advice given that i just did it
well i'm going to tell you what i'm
going to do tomorrow when i inevitably
hit that creative block
is emotional eating you know that it's
emotional if it's
comes on suddenly if you
aren't just craving something but you
are
reaching for something that is a treat
or that's soothing
and before i do that tomorrow when my
writer's block inevitably happens again
i will take a deep breath and i will ask
myself what am i feeling
[Music]
why
am i reaching for this food am i hungry
or am i trying to soothe or comfort or
distract myself because i was clearly
trying to soothe and distract myself
from the feelings that writer's block
was bringing up
and now
i need to
get some gas sex or something
because i gotta distract myself from the
gas pains that i have from my emotional
eating
but you know honestly the discomfort i'm
feeling right now that's not gonna stop
me from doing it tomorrow the only thing
that will stop this pattern is spotting
the pattern and using the tools that i
just gave you identify what you're
feeling ask you why it is you're
reaching for this if you're not hungry
but you're trying to soothe distract or
reward yourself you're feeding some
feeling
recognize the feeling put down the ice
cream go for a walk choose something
healthy
address the feeling
don't reach for the food so there are
7.5 billion people on this incredible
planet of ours but do you know how many
of them you're responsible for truly
one you see while you're busy taking
care of everybody else who is it that's
taking care of you you were given one
human being one mind one soul one body
one life we are so
bananas focused about what people who
know nothing
about what's going on in your life thing
and what happens is you can get so
concerned about the opinions and the
judgments of all these other people that
you're taking care of and that you're
being nice to that you forget about the
one person's opinion that actually
matters and that's yours and when
silencing yourself and being way more
concerned about what everybody thinks
becomes a pattern you are holding
yourself back you don't go after your
dreams because you're way too caught up
in what everybody else is thinking for
every person that's got a side eye or an
eye roll or an opinion about what you're
doing i promise you when you make the
decision to live your life for you
the right people will find you is this
going to be easy to chart your own path
to hear what people have to say but not
let it define what you do next
it's going to take a little bit of
practice but once you make the decision
to live your life for you i promise you
everything will fall into place my
sparkly sneakers this is a great story
about a bunch of topics it's a story
about confidence it's a story about
being comfortable in your own skin it's
a story about being yourself no matter
where you are or what you're doing and
it's a story about the power
of your unique self-expression and your
unique self-expression comes out and is
amplified when you feel comfortable in
your own skin i got into the speaking
business gosh six or seven years ago i
had a tedx talk that went crazy viral
that's what started the speaking
business and when i first got into the
speaking business
i was really intimidated because i was
new to it and i wanted to do a very good
job and i wanted to fit in so i looked
around at what all the top people in the
industry of motivational speaking and
speaking on the corporate circuit were
doing
and i noticed that all the women
were dressed in heels wearing pencil
skirts or beautiful dresses the kind of
thing that you might see a news anchor
wearing like a nice dress heels so i
just wore what everybody else was
wearing didn't even occur to me to wear
something else because here i am trying
to break into a new industry so i look
at everybody at the top i copy what
they're doing and i am not
comfortable in high heels yes if my
husband chris and i are going out on
date night i can rock them like the best
of them but walking through a convention
center in them
standing on a stage for an hour and a
pair of heels while you're trying to
hold in your stomach because you're
being broadcast on a big screen and
you're wearing a dress like it was
the
least comfortable outfit i could
possibly wear very self-conscious in it
i'm not that graceful in a pair of heels
so i sort of like
poop
on a stage
but that's what i did for the first
couple years
so i was in miami this must have been
probably five years ago i was in miami
and i just gotten off stage take off the
heels take off the dress put on a pair
of jeans and a t-shirt i got like an
hour to kill before i have to leave for
the airport i'm gonna fly to vegas
because i've got a speech in vegas the
next morning so i'm walking uh down
collins ave in south beach in miami
and
i walk past this store
unfortunately it's not there anymore i
love this store
and there in the window
were the most amazing high-top sneakers
i had ever seen in my entire life i was
like a moth to the flame
let me show you these bad boys because
these are the originals
this right here
notice the gold shimmery sparkle
and the
confident blaze orange i didn't own
anything like this i'd never seen
anything like this i immediately thought
whoa this
i bet is what like a justin bieber kind
of wears i mean these are insanely cool
i went inside
and they were
pretty expensive i'd never spent that
kind of my i wasn't a sneaker head yet
but i thought hey i i i spend that kind
of money on a pair of nice heels so why
not treat myself to a pair of sneakers
okay
so i get back to the hotel i pack up i
hop the flight i get to vegas now i wake
up the next morning and i have a tech
check which is where you rehearse the
speech and go through like all the
technology rehearsals before the events
starting my tech check is at 7 30 the
doors to the event open at 8 and i'm on
stage at 8 30. and i had a red dress my
heels or so i thought
so i crack open that's what i was
planning on wearing i crack open the
suitcase there are no heels
i have left the heels
in the hotel room back in miami all i
have are the birkenstocks that i wore on
the plane and i wore out in vegas last
night
and my new justin bieber high top
sneakers and i have exactly 15 minutes
to get to the tech rehearsal and nothing
else is open so birkenstocks justin
bieber i think we'll go with the justin
bieber sparkly high tops i slapped those
puppies on i walked from my hotel room
all the way through the casino floor
past all the restaurants and the shops
to the convention center which you know
is like a two mile walk i was so happy
to be not only in my red dress but more
importantly in my justin bieber sneakers
because it was super comfortable to walk
there that way i get to the backstage
area and for the first time in two years
something happened and let me tell you
what happened
one of the guys that was on the
production crew
turned
and goes
ah
cool sneakers that was like the first
time
somebody in production had really
acknowledged me for something other than
the job in two years so i was like huh
and as i started walking toward the
backstage area everybody i passed cool
kicks oh those are cool well those are
cool and i'm like
this is wild nobody's ever complimented
on my like this is people are
and so i did the tech rehearsal and then
this was the moment of truth when i
walked out onto that stage it was at the
mgm arena
and uh there were like 5 000 real estate
agents in the audience i was there to
deliver a speech for re max
it was the first time i'd ever walked on
a stage
where i actually felt like myself
it was also the first time
that i felt the audience
kind of lean forward
and go oh
she seems kind of cool but when you walk
onto a stage and heals an address you're
like the authority
and you're on a stage and you're talking
at people
there's something about walking onto a
stage or walking through life and having
something fun that you're wearing that
makes you
relatable and interesting and real
and from that moment forward i have
never
not worn sparkly speakers for work i
wore them every day on my daytime talk
show
i'm embarrassed to tell you
that i probably have 20 pairs of these i
love this is my favorite these are my
favorite well i like these are my
favorite because these are the originals
but i would say these are my second
favorite because i like the low top and
i love the blue
i love these
um which have a big silver kind of thing
these are super comfortable and i've got
a bunch of these and these did not even
come with sparkles so i literally bought
swivarsky crystals or whatever the hell
they're called and got a glue gun out
and put them on myself
if you're looking for sparkly sneakers
there's all kinds of them out there
these days it's the coolest thing in the
world but dazzled me sneakers are a
thing
whether you go to dsw or nordstroms or
zappos or anywhere you can find them and
so the moral of the story the secret to
confidence is being comfortable in your
own skin i have this habit of every
single morning i stand in front of the
mirror and i take a moment and i raise
my hand
and i give my reflection a high five and
there is so much science behind this so
instead of seeing yourself
right and have having this moment in the
mirror you know what the average person
does first of all we beat ourselves down
so i would look in the mirror for 40
some years and be like oh my god my
freaking jowls look like saddlebags on a
goddamn horse going in the grand canyon
my eyes have a my neck is only striped
my boob one boob's hanging lower than
the other i look like my gray hair like
i start bringing myself down
and when you start going down that road
with your reflection
then your thoughts go to i didn't get to
that email i forgot to text lisa back i
oh my gosh the dog still needs to be
walked i've got nine minutes for my
first zoom you're now
checking out and that moment in the
mirror every morning
could be a profound moment
where you lift yourself up
and you check back in with your
intention
so the first piece of research and this
is recent from harvard business school
is that a simple moment
in the morning
where you set an intention
about who you're going to be today
impacts productivity how you show up as
a leader
it impacts your confidence it impacts
your mood all day long just that simple
moment of setting an intention so that's
research number one instead of
standing in front of the sink in your
bathroom and criticizing your appearance
or mindlessly going on autopilot
check back in and let's teach you to
make it a habit to lift yourself back up
second piece of research and this comes
from a whole field of study called
neurobics neurobics is like aerobics for
your mind i didn't make this up
this is
literally you can speed up the
development of new neural pathways by
marrying physical activity
with a change in thought
and so traditionally i know you've
covered this on your show if you for
example were to brush your teeth i'm a
right-hander if you were to brush it
with your other hand
and think
a new thought
the fact that your brain is focusing on
brushing with your non-dominant hand
activates more focus on the new thought
it accelerates the learning so you take
neurobics a physical activity with a
different thought and let me let's talk
about a high five for example
what does a high five mean to you
that somebody did something awesome or i
did something awesome correct and if you
think about the times in your life when
you've gotten a high five
it's because somebody's like tom you're
amazing tom
get your attitude out of the can you got
this tom you're gonna make this shot tom
we can still win i believe in you keep
going
you have a lifetime positive association
with giving other people high fives
stored right here in your subconscious
mind when you raise your hand to your
own reflection it is impossible for you
to think god i look fat why am i an
[ __ ] i really screwed up my life you
can't do it because your lifetime
association with this motion is all i
believe in you i got you i see you i
celebrate you and so you in the moment
of doing it override decades of negative
self-talk it's incredible
now have you ever gotten a high five
where somebody misses the hand or it's
sort of like it sucks right
yeah what do you do when that happens i
redo it correct
that's because a high five requires you
to be present and there is an intention
behind it
so you can't raise your hand to your own
reflection without now grounding
yourself in the moment i don't believe
in toxic positivity i don't believe that
you just like put a positive spin on
things and things will disappear and be
fine that's not how the world works
there are very real challenges that you
may be facing you may be facing abuse
violence you may be up against
structural and systematic racism and
bias and discrimination you may be
facing extreme poverty you may be facing
all kinds of very real and traumatic
things in your life
simply putting a positive spin on things
will not change those very real
obstacles what it changes is you
when you change how you look at things
it changes your ability to deal with the
things in your life it changes your
ability to face hard things and it gives
you the courage and the confidence and
the resilience and the stamina to chip
away at these large obstacles or these
past experiences that created trauma or
negative self-talk it's going to give
you the ability to take the action that
you need and so when you hear me talk
about mindset i want you to understand
this doesn't make things disappear it
actually empowers you to be your
greatest self to face the stuff that's
very difficult you know because
confidence courage resilience these are
all things that are inside you and you
don't build this stuff
in the high moments you build your
confidence and your courage and your
resilience in the low moments it's like
steel it's forged in the fire of your
life and so even in those moments where
you feel like life is punching you in
the face and you just want to give up
and you have that like i can't handle
this anymore and why does this keep
happening to me i am telling you do not
give up because you are building your
inner strength every step of the way
through these experiences that you're
facing in your life i'm not saying it's
fair
i'm not saying you deserve it i'm saying
you have the power within you to face
whatever you're dealing with to find
your strength and to actually change
yourself and the situation and the
trajectory that you're on for the better
there is no fast track to transformation
you have to work on it in little ways
every day you can't buy self-esteem or
self-love you must build it you must
stand face to face with the part of you
that you hate
you must forgive yourself for the hurt
that you've caused especially the hurt
you've caused yourself
and then you've got to do the work to
become a better you
it's the only way to create the
self-respect and build the self-esteem
that you want you can change there are
do-overs in life because you get one
every single morning when you wake up
look in the mirror and decide who you're
going to be today you can choose you can
change no you can't go back in time but
you can have your own back as you use
the time that you have now to take
control and create a new chapter that
makes you proud of who you are the
hardest part of all this is flipping
your focus
from what you hate and are trying to fix
toward what you want to create
remember the windshield in a car is
bigger than the rear view mirror for
good reason you're not supposed to go
backwards you're supposed to drive your
life forward and that means you must
start looking ahead
yeah you screwed up me too the worst
things that you've done witnessed or
survived they are your most powerful
teachers so stop making yourself wrong
about what happened and unpack it
understand it
face yourself in the mirror and learn
the lessons that are woven into every
mistake
every regret you ever have and every
painful thing you've ever experienced
here's the profound insight i gained
that i want you to hear
you aren't broken
you're just blocked
forgive yourself for all the things you
did while you were just trying to
survive the dallas uber driver oh so as
somebody who has gotten into
countless ubers and some small
percentage of them know who i am and
then of course they start asking
questions
talk to me about chasing your dreams and
this quote that you have that an aha
moment does not necessarily lead to an
aha life
um
yeah the uber driver in dallas that's in
this book um i get choked up when i
think about him
uh an aha moment choked up
i get choked up
because
what happens for me every single day is
and you hear from people every single
day
you've got millions and millions of
people that
are inspired by empowered by impacted by
your content there are people out there
that
use your work as a lifeline
and it is humbling
and what i am
really present to
in the work that i'm putting out in the
stuff that i'm sharing whether it's my
failures or the things that i'm using
that are helping me and my own struggles
is just
how much people are holding themselves
back
and how
much pain people feel
because
most folks know
what they dream about
and what they want
and yet
they're spending all of their time and
energy arguing against
what they want
and so you can have all these epiphanies
i hope that when somebody listens to our
conversation and watches this that they
have a massive aha moment
but it's not going to mean
if you don't take action and do
something about it
the aha moment is the door that opens
but your new life does not begin unless
you step through the door and most
people and that's what was
so kind of
you know the simple idea of high-fiving
yourself of encouraging yourself of
supporting yourself most people when you
have an aha moment and the door to your
new life opens up
instead of going i got this let's go and
high-fiving yourself to step forward
most of us go
i don't know if i'm worth that i don't
know if right now is the right time to
do this i don't think i'm good enough i
failed so many times i can't go through
that door
and that's the problem i want to attack
right now that there is somewhere in
your life
that you know what you want
you can feel it pulling you
and you are actively arguing against it
you're bringing yourself down you're
beating yourself out like people will
cheer for you and me they won't cheer
for themselves
i'm the same way
and so this uber driver
the story that you're talking about i
get into the car
and
we start driving and i'm on the phone as
we're driving and i'm having a
conversation with somebody about this
daytime talk show that i launched which
was a dream with sony pictures
television and then
uh was promptly fired after season one
it was a huge failure because we didn't
make it to season two
huge failure in real world terms
massive success when it comes to the
timeline of my life
and so i'm talking to this person about
the talk show i hang up the phone and
this uber driver comes alive he's like
oh my gosh i can't believe you're in my
cab
and i'm like why and he says because i i
want to talk to you about something i
think you can help me and i'm like great
how can i help you and he says
i have a dream of being a oscar-winning
actor and creating opportunities for
other black and latino men to do the
same in acting and i'm like freaking
fantastic what the [ __ ] are you doing in
dallas
right yeah the guy's 25 and so
i i go you know the game is in new york
in la i mean sure you can act you can
write stuff you can be here in dallas
but why are you not in la why are you
not in new york and he's like you're
right you're right you're right i need
to move to la like why not
and he says i have 700 in my bank
account and i'm like that's freaking
fantastic you have 700 in a car
dude drop me off and get driving what
are you waiting for and so we have this
whole conversation and i write about it
in this book
where
i am actively arguing for his dream and
he is actively arguing against his dream
and
what is so sad
is throughout this conversation tom he's
like you're right seven hundred could
get me there you're right i am only 25.
you're right if i keep thinking and
thinking and thinking and thinking about
what i want to be doing i'm not only
going to drive in circles my whole life
is going to spin in circles as i think
about what i want and i don't do [ __ ]
about it
and then you are going to find yourself
not at 25 but at 45 or 65 and you're
going to be so filled with regret that
you never put a put a bet on yourself
and so
this conversation ends with him
declaring that he's going to go to
california and me giving him a bunch of
tools that i talk about in this book
and the point of the story is does he
move or not i don't know
the point of the story is it's so easy
to see what somebody else should do it's
so easy to cheer for somebody else we
all do that right we cheer for our
favorite sports teams we follow our
favorite influencers and authors we plan
birthday parties for our friends we take
on extra work from our colleagues we
support everyone around us
we do not know how to do it for
ourselves there are four techniques that
i use whenever i'm gonna have a
difficult conversation that helped me
stay focused on what i need to talk
about instead of getting hijacked by my
emotions number one i always start the
conversation by acknowledging
my responsibility in the mess that we
have to talk about whether it's the fact
that i've avoided dealing with this
sooner or whether there's something that
i've done that's contributed to the
situation i acknowledge it right up
front and one of the reasons why that's
so important is because by accepting
some responsibility you're diffusing the
other person's emotion
you're also honoring them a little bit
and it sets a much more level playing
field for when you get into the
difficult things that you need to talk
about it's also going to put the person
that you're speaking to
a little at ease so they're going to be
able to listen number two you want to
have a goal
never go into a difficult conversation
without an outcome defined before you go
into it the reason why the outcome is so
important is because this conversation
is going to be a roller coaster the
person that you're talking to might get
upset you yourself might feel emotional
at some point whether you're angry or
you're triggered or you get sad and so
when you ride the roller coaster of
emotion the thing that is going to
stabilize your thoughts is the outcome
that you're causing you're having this
conversation because you're committed to
making the relationship better you're
having this conversation because this
isn't working and so we need to end it
powerfully you're having this
conversation because you want to give
somebody some feedback that's not so fun
to tell them but you're giving it to
them because you're committed to their
success okay so that goal you feel
yourself getting emotional you come back
to it you come back to it you come back
to it
third thing you're gonna do a lot in
this conversation you're gonna listen
and you're gonna validate
so you're going to say what you need to
say and then the other person's going to
react
and instead of arguing or debating i
want you to listen and i want you to
validate what the person is saying may
sound counterintuitive but honestly one
of the most powerful things you can do
in any conversation whether you're
fighting with your kids over curfew or
you're arguing with somebody at work
over workloads whatever it may be is
here where the person's at
the moment you say wow
that must be really tough
what you're dealing with or
oh i totally get why you now were
avoiding me
if i felt the way that you felt i'd
probably do the same thing
the second you validate somebody they
immediately stop defending themselves
it's unbelievable actually
unbelievable you've got to try it
validate validate validate it is the
most powerful thing and then once of
course they feel validated that you've
heard them now they can listen and
that's when you come back to the final
thing which is you're going to restate
always the outcome
keep coming back to it keep coming back
to it
and yeah it's not going to be fun
it's not going to be easy
you're going to have all kinds of
emotions come up because you've been
avoiding this conversation
but i'm telling you right now
if you find the confidence and the
courage to go and to start this thing
knowledge your responsibility have an
outcome in mind validate the other
person validate validate validate and
keep talking till you hit that outcome
you're going to be really really amazed
at how much easier these things become
and if you want to make it even easier
on yourself rehearse it with another
friend first somebody that's not
involved in the situation because again
difficult conversations comes down to
one important thing
the ability for you to separate your
emotion about doing it from the things
you actually need to talk about and the
outcome that you want to cause let's
start with a metaphor
i want you to think about your life like
a book
a book is divided into chapters
some chapters are boring and a grind to
get through and others are exciting and
you hope they never end and right now
you're in a chapter
[Music]
maybe this chapter of your life is a
grind it's overwhelming and unsatisfying
and you feel stuck reading it over and
over again maybe you want to start a new
chapter but you don't know what the next
chapter is about and so you keep
re-reading the one you're currently in
here's the greatest thing about life
you don't have to know where this next
chapter is going you just have to start
writing it
i want you to envision a blank page
what do you want to write
what do you see for yourself
i don't want you to try to figure out
what job or business you should write on
that page what belongs on that page are
the dreams that you have for yourself
and your life
and all that's required to start writing
is to start saying yes instead of
telling yourself no
yes you should start that podcast
yes you should go back to school
yes you should try to launch that
business
whatever it is that you've been doing
whether you're three years out of
college and it's a job you can't stand
from a major you hate or it's a 20-year
career that you're just burnt out on
or maybe you stepped away from the
workforce to raise your kids or perhaps
like so many people right now you've
been laid off
this
is the moment to write your next chapter
you're not too late
[Music]
you're right on time
all you need is a blank page
and a pen one of the things that i think
you should always come back to
first is take a look at how you set your
day up because how you set it up is how
it ends up how do i set my day up
so that i'm practicing what i call
simple discipline simple discipline is
nothing more than making and keeping
simple promises to yourself repeating it
every day the way that you start to
change the big things is you change the
small things make tiny teeny teeny
promises to yourself and then keep them
so how do you build simple discipline
here are some core skills that i do
every morning that have helped me number
one
i do not sleep with the phone
number two
when the alarm goes off on my phone it's
not near me so i have to get my ass out
of bed i get up i make my bed i get
moving
i get my exercise clothes on i move my
body i then journal i take 10 minutes to
myself to plan my day when i do that my
day is incredible i believe that how you
start your day dictates how the day goes
you should not just adopt somebody
else's morning routine and expect it to
work for you you need to customize this
you are unique i think about how do you
come alive for yourself in the morning
what are the five senses what's the
first thing that you see
when you wake up for me it's a painting
that i manifested out of thin air it
reminds me that what you put your mind
to and what you work toward
it will become a reality i always light
incense because it makes my senses and
my nose come alive i'm super mindful
over what i taste first thing in the
morning my grandma always had vinegar in
the morning with honey and hot water i
picked the one thing that matters to me
today one of the biggest objections that
people had to
standing in front of the mirror take a
moment look at yourself and then raise
your hand
as people said over and over and over
again
i haven't done anything
worthy
of high-fiving
high-fiving feels like a celebration
i don't have the number on the scale
that i want
i don't like my bank account i don't
enjoy what i do for a living i've made a
load of mistakes i'm struggling with
trauma
i don't have anything to celebrate
and what i realized is
people are making a fundamental mistake
you are withholding the very support
empowerment and celebration that you
need to change and to do the hard work
and to face the things that you're
scared of
and that's why you're not changing i
think that confidence is the willingness
to try see i anchor confidence in action
because i don't believe
that belief in self
is the thing
that makes people
act confidently
i believe that when you
are willing to try even though you doubt
yourself
that
the act of trying
and seeing yourself move through your
doubts and your fears and your
procrastination and your perfectionism
the act of moving through it is what
starts to build belief in self
so i define confidence as the
willingness to try
arrogance is believing you're better
than anybody else
and i think confidence is this quiet
knowing that you can rely on yourself
even the most confident people so people
that rely on themselves and people that
are willing to try and take risks
um
hit periods where they really doubt
themselves and they don't feel confident
in their decision making and their
actions and so i think it's a skill that
comes and goes and that you'll always be
working on it because the whole point
about life is to grow and as you grow
you're going to face new challenges and
whenever you face a new challenge it's
going to
you know bring up fears and doubt and
that's why you're going to need to work
on the skill of confidence which is the
willingness to try that's where it
begins i am making cabbage faro soup it
sounds disgusting it is delicious it is
from my absolute favorite
cookbook six seasons by joshua mcfadden
but that's not why i made this video
i made this video because i want to
share a recipe for
relieving pain tension frustration and
hurt in your life
every day all kinds of stuff happens to
you right some good some bad some
frustrating some
some things that are amazing
and
for everything that happens to you there
are three versions
of what happens
there's your version and the story that
you tell yourself about what happened
there's a second version which is the
version that the other person that's
involved in the story
tells themselves about what happened
and then there's the truth
and the truth is just the facts
no story no explanation it's just what
so so i'm going to give you a quick
example so i'm sitting here cooking
and
um i've got a lot i got to clean up i've
got stuff all over the counter i've been
working on some architectural plans over
there i got to clean that up so i'm
starting to clean up and i come over
here to the sink
and i notice
someone that i loves egg dish is right
there
now
i'm not gonna out them i'm also gonna
not out the fact that part of the uh
breakfast uh that they were creating for
themselves which involved
uh sweet potato and making some eggs is
still out and that said person is
nowhere to be found
so let's talk about the three versions
of this story
version number one is my version
which goes a little something like why
does my family
believe
that i
am the maid this is being done to me how
rude they expect me to do this
like on and on and on you can see that
story about the fact
that there is an egg dish here
and there are knives that need to be
cleaned that story i'm telling myself
gets me really jacked up and angry and
frustrated and feeling used and annoyed
and of course when your mood switches it
can hijack your whole day
now
version number two
would probably be
holy cow i'm coming back later of course
you don't need to clean it up
i'm just in an online
uh jam session
working on a song i have to record
for my class
and in fact
if we're quiet
[Music]
now here's the cool part
you don't have to tell yourself a story
you can just see something and not make
it mean anything
at all and in fact here she comes
she's done doing her thing and she's
coming back in to clean up i torture
myself and you torture yourself for no
good reason
so
check your story
stick with the facts and i think you'll
find that life is a lot
less stressful and frustrating i have
been practicing this habit for
a little over a year
and it all began in april of 2020 and
this is not something that i was like
okay i got to write a book it's got to
have a five in it it's going to be five
years since i've written a book thank
you dyslexia and adhd what am i going to
write about what am i that's not how
this happened
the high five habit
saved me
it was a ladder that helped me climb out
of a hole i had fallen into emotionally
physically spiritually and
a year later
after practicing what is going to sound
like a weird
stupid thing
which you will resist and jay you and i
are going to unpack this because it's
sad why everybody resists it
it has to do with the dust that's
accumulated
and i will tell you after a year
of practicing this
i don't even see
a face or a body
i see a soul i don't even have to
high-five myself i still do because it
feels good and we're gonna explain the
science yes that is bananas about why
this actually works for everybody who
tries it
because this is not something that's new
you are tapping into programming that's
already in your mind and body and now
directing it back at yourself it's
incredible
i
don't ever criticize myself
i don't ever see what's wrong
i see a human being who's trying
who deserves love and respect and i know
that it's my job to give it to her
you know the five second rule which i
created i don't know over a decade ago
that's gone on to help me change my
whole life it's a little starting ritual
and a brain hack that you can use to
help yourself take the actions and
change the thoughts that change your
life
it helped me be more productive it
helped me get stuff done
the high five habit has changed who i am
it has deleted a lifetime of criticism
and negativity from my mind and it has
reprogrammed the soundtrack to be
somebody that's supportive and a
cheerleader it's extraordinary my brand
of self-help is mel's life is kind of
[ __ ] up at the moment and she can't
figure out how to help herself so she
stumbles by accident on something really
stupid on its face
and it feels good
and then i share it with my audience and
if they pick up on it and they then i'm
like okay we're on to something so for
me the high five tom began i'm fired
from my talk show my book contract is
canceled every speech has been canceled
my kids are now home so we've got three
kids 22 20
age 15 all in varying states of distress
i am triggered because my origin story
as you know from being on the show and
us being friends the five second rule
was 12 years ago losing everything and
so i'm now having this feeling like i'm
about to lose everything and i'm also
feeling like i'm losing grip on reality
as the pandemic is hitting and as my
kids are in distress and i don't know
what to do just like everybody on the
planet i find myself in my bathroom one
morning in my underwear
and i am having
this spiral of negative thoughts i look
like
i don't know how to fix this
i wish somebody would solve this for me
i feel overwhelmed i feel scared about
my parents health i feel scared about
everybody on the front lines
and even though i'm literally like you
somebody that empowers other people i
didn't know what to say to myself
and as pathetic as it sounds i found
myself just raising my hand
just in a way to basically be like
shut up mel come on girl you like put
your shoulders back lift your you you
got this
you can do this
and something shifted and i went on with
my day and then the next morning i walk
into my bathroom and this is the other
weird thing about the high five i've
literally either criticized myself or
ignored myself in the mirror
for decades
when you start to have a moment with
yourself
the crazy part is you start to build a
partnership with yourself that's
interesting
like
you know when you are pulling out of
your driveway or you're walking down the
street you see a neighbor and they greet
you
you will start to have that experience
when you create this intentional moment
with yourself in the mirror every
morning
and so
as i started to do this
i thought this is actually
making me feel like the wind is at my
back when i leave the bathroom it's
making me feel just like when you leave
a huddle in sports and you high five or
you're a runner running a race or doing
some big endurance challenge and some
spectator high-fives you or another
racer is like come on you got this as
you're dragging down low
it gives you a little energy
like i think too about this high five a
lot like i know you know you're friends
with david goggins i'm a huge fan of
goggins and so and i know there's a lot
of people that watch this show
especially men they're like this sounds
kind of stupid this is the equivalent of
goggins cookie jar moment
so we all think like we've all been
raised like tough love heart almost
bullsh
the research is clear on this
being hard on yourself is not motivating
it's demotivating
and if you already feel like a failure
or you feel a sense of shame or you're
overwhelmed beating yourself up for
where you are does not work
it drives you into the gutter
the most motivating force in the world
on the planet based on research hands
down
is empowerment encouragement support and
celebration and for our entire lives we
have outsourced that to somebody else
the research is very clear so the nba
study they did this big study looking at
nba teams and they could predict in the
study who was going to be in the
championship rounds
based on in the preseason what teams had
the most high fives fist bumps and
backpacks why
because those kind of gestures create
partnership and trust and i'm here to
tell you when you start doing it in the
mirror you're creating partnership and
trust with yourself
i'm gonna take everybody back
four years ago
so this is the
first book the high five habit is the
first book that i have written and
published in almost five years
back in 2007 i released a book called
the five-second rule
and
lisa and her husband tom
played a pivotal role
in one of the biggest professional
breakdowns of my life and they had no
idea that it was happening at the time
no clue and lisa i think you just found
out about it by reading about it in
chapter 12 of my new book yeah so here's
what was going on
i had written the five-second rule book
i had self-published it because i
thought that um that was the best thing
to do
i had a dream of being a number one new
york times best-selling author
and i put it up on my vision board and i
dreamed about it and i thought about it
and i studied all the authors that we
all admire and i did my best to do all
the things that you uh are supposed to
do
in order to sell enough books to grace
the new york times bestseller list right
so i email my newsletter list and i am
doing speeches all over the place and
i'm pre-selling books as best i can in
the back of a room with my pad of paper
taking people's like literally for
months
i
did everything i could
and when the book came out
i sent the email out to everybody
and
folks on my email list and everybody i'm
related to immediately went to amazon to
buy the book
and here's what happened within an hour
or two the book was listed as out of
stock now i thought
yes
yes
i have won i am a best-selling author i
am sold out of amazon in a matter of a
few hours oh my god oh my god this like
literally this this proves all the
things that everybody said about me in
middle school is not true anymore i
i've done it lisa
and then i started to realize i had not
sold all the books because i did not
have i had twenty thousand books at
amazon i did not have that many people
on my email list and people started to
email back going it's out of stock it's
out of stock it's honestly you think
your dream like the height of your
freaking dreams come true yes i think
i've done it like i've so like i am a
success i'm a phenomenon this is
unbelievable i think the dreams are
coming true and then within a couple
hours people start emailing going it's
out of stock mal it's out of stock it's
out of stock it's out of stock
it dawns on me there's no way i sold 20
000 books there's no way
i call the printer that i worked with
that helped me self-publish and you know
it's a little self-publishing publisher
and he tells me that
he's seen this happen before where when
amazon gets a flood of
traffic to something that they're not
expecting
they will turn off supply
to make sure it's not a bunch of bots
and to also check inventory
and we had no ability
to
figure this out so for the first couple
weeks that the book was available it was
out of stock
so here i am
in
this two-week period
where i have worked my
ass off i have done everything you're
supposed to do lisa
and my book is out of stock
i have sent my entire marketing campaign
to a product you can't get and i'm
thinking why are you doing this to me
universe
i have worked hard why do i have to be
the bad news bears why am i not part of
that super like awesome group of
best-selling authors one is it going to
be my turn and i start to go down the
drain
enter
tom and lisa villa
so
when i come here
and i am doing your show
i show up here and i'm like this is my
last hope because by the time this thing
gets on air maybe the book will be
available i have got to pull myself
together so i walk in here and i was
just i i didn't know you yet because i
only knew like impact theory and i only
seen it i knew this was a big deal i
knew that being on tom's show could
really like change things for me and i
walk in here and i feel like a complete
failure
you are lovely and delightful and i
immediately start feeling like i don't
freaking belong here i mean they just
had this best-selling author and that
best-selling offer and this famous
person was just here what am i doing
here i am a self-published author with a
book that's out of stock
like i'm i'm
failing
i hope that they don't know
because this is terrible like the he is
going to figure out before i enter the
set that i don't belong here you think
imposter syndrome
oh completely
so i'm upstairs in the bathroom and i am
having a case no kidding of stress
diarrhea like i
have got to empty the bowels because i
am so sure that i'm about to be called
out for the fraud that i am that the
book is not successful that tom's made a
mistake i look at the mirror my cheeks
are as red as a baboon's ass i am
sweating profusely i've got pit stains
on my red shirt and then there's a knock
on the door we're ready for you mel
i splash water on my face
i literally am like
five four three two one like
pull your shirt together mel get the
[ __ ] out there and i open up the door
and i go and one of the things that you
believe that i believe too is that your
feelings are gonna rise and they're
gonna fall
and feeling nervous and feeling scared
and feeling on edge and imposter
syndrome it's all normal stuff
you got to develop the ability to feel
all that stuff
have your cheeks be as red as a baboon's
butt
and walk out there and do it anyway
that's what you've got to develop in
life and that moment taught me that and
there was something else that happened
so when i left that set
the whole time that the book was out of
stock and i'm sitting here going woe is
me and i've failed again and i screw
everything up and why doesn't anything
ever work out for me
i would catch myself
and i would say this
there's no way mel that you've worked
this hard
that something amazing isn't going to
happen
you have to keep going
you have to believe that this moment is
preparing you for something amazing that
hasn't happened yet the talk show
experience
was
almost
like it's it's weird it almost feels
like it didn't happen
really
yeah it was your whole life for like two
years
yeah but you know 175 shows it was in
super intense
you know it was it was almost a
spiritual experience because
i had dreamt about it for as long as i
could remember
and i stepped onto that talk show set
with such a level of mastery
and the reason why
i had a level of mastery
is because i could look backwards at my
life
and see that i had been
heading to that moment for my entire
life
that the ability to create trust and
take a complicated amount of information
and
get down to the human connection
immediately that began
back in 1994 when i was a legal aid
attorney doing criminal defense work in
new york city
my ability to understand what victims of
domestic violence go through
uh goes all the way back to
1986 through 1988 when i was a crisis
intervention counselor volunteering on a
domestic violence hotline
my ability to read a teleprompter had to
do with being at cnn my ability to work
18-hour days uh was a function of the
reality tv show world my ability to
relate to somebody who had lost
everything was a function of what chris
and i had gone through my ability like
just everything
all of a sudden was like
and it's why i can say with such urgency
that you have to have faith that this is
happening for a reason that this is
leading somewhere you know when you're
about to meet a friend somebody you
really like at a cafe
you're gonna go have a cup of tea
what do you feel right before you walk
in the door
excitement enthusiasm energy joy uh
positive nervousness like that that kind
of like uh
butterflies even in a positive sense
yeah so at this moment i was 51 years
old
in 51 years of being alive i don't ever
remember
feeling
that feeling about seeing myself wow
for the first time in my life i had this
sensation
that i was excited
to see the human being mel robbins now
i've been excited to see an outfit
or excited to see a haircut
i have never been excited to see the
person
and so i round the corner and this
sense of how profound this is is hitting
me
and i'm standing there
brushing my teeth and i realize
something really wild
there are always two of you in the
bathroom together
there's you
and there is a human being in the mirror
a person who needs you
a person who has been waiting for you to
wake up and realize they are there
and they need you to see them and to
hear them and to love them and to
support them
and so what's interesting because you
brought up morning routines right is
that we all talk about the importance of
setting our day up because it's how it
ends up we talk about gratitude and
meditation and we know the extraordinary
benefits of it
but i don't think anybody has truly
amplified the fact that there is this
dirty habit that we all have
every single morning that is a part of
your morning routine unless you have
weeded this out
and it is a habit of either ignoring
yourself
or
beating the heck out of yourself
every single morning in the mirror i
mean 91 of women don't like how they
look
50 of us can't even look at ourselves in
the mirror you're a big proponent of the
growth mindset you guys talk about it
all the time on this show right so
researchers wanted to know what is the
most empowering way to motivate kids
through a really big challenge okay they
divide the kids into three groups this
takes the marshmallow test to a whole
other level you got one group of kids
that are doing a challenging task and
they're getting the fixed mindset praise
which we all know does not work oh tom
you're so smart oh tom i love your
glasses that's gonna help you oh tom you
got a great smile oh tom you know i i
just love so much about you i know you
can do this so that's one group the
second group gets the growth mindset
kind of phrase tom you are such a hard
worker tom your perseverance is
unbelievable tom you just keep going
that does better obviously than telling
you that you're smart because it makes
you motivated to work hard the third
group
they just got a simple high five the
researchers didn't even say anything to
the kids they just walked up gave them a
high five the group of kids that got a
simple high five outperformed outworked
through all of the challenges all of the
other forms of praise why
because a high five is something deeper
than praise
it fulfills your most fundamental needs
as a human being
when somebody high-fives you you feel
seen
you feel heard
and you feel like somebody has
acknowledged
you for the unique person that you are i
literally when i think back three years
ago where i was like saw one of your
videos or gary's videos or somebody i'm
like oh
i just need to start filming the book
lines at these
and it was a it was a moment it was this
little amount of wisdom inside of me
that i listened to
and i am telling you that is the power
you got to tune out the noise and you
got to learn how to make what i call a
quiet decision yeah quiet decision where
you sh
and you hear what your heart is is
urging you to do your mind collects
mental in
that's right that's all that doubt is
that's all that fear is that's all that
anxiety is that's all that worry is it's
all the people pleasing is
this is lint from life that is collected
in your brain and you know what lint
stands for something get your pencils
ready
you lose inspiration due to negative
thoughts
that's all that's happening
you're not broken you're just blocked
the filter in your mind is blocked just
like a dryer filter gets blocked by lint
and you can't think this stuff away you
got to take action
and the single most effective tool on
the planet hands down
to wipe away the lint in your mind to
wipe away the doubt to wipe away the
fear to wipe away the anxiety is the
five second rule
i'm dead serious about this
when you feel
the fear rise up when you feel the
self-doubt start to block
when you feel the anxiety start to take
over when you feel like you're losing
the inspiration move you're just gonna
count backwards five four three two one
i know it sounds dumb
but trust me on this one counting
backwards five four three two one wipes
the lint
off the filter in your brain
that lint that makes you lose your
inspiration to act due to negative
thoughts
and once you get to one it's clear
so your confidence and your courage can
flow right through you if you can't
stand in front of the mirror
and raise your hand
and high five yourself just because you
got your ass out of bed
and you're breathing
you will never get what you want in life
ever there is something in the
resistance to it and if you unpack the
resistance
you will find the reason why you don't
have what you want you either think
you're not worthy of it or you think
that it's kind of stupid or you have
been brought up to believe that
for women in particular you're going to
be [ __ ] or selfish or not likable if
you're celebrating yourself there is
something in the resistance to you
simply
cheering for yourself your interview
releases
and
i all of a sudden get this email from
audible i had forgotten
that i had published an audio book
i had self-published that too
my husband had uploaded it himself to
the amazon platform called acx which is
a self-publishing platform for audible
i had completely forgotten about the
audio book because i was so
focused on this new york times things
and by the way here's another thing
you can't make the new york times list
if you're a self-published author
something i didn't even know when i
started
so
here i thought i'd fail didn't achieve
my dream the whole thing
i get this email
your monthly report is ready and i'm
like monthly report what are they
talking about
i click on that report i open it up i am
literally like oh
my god
audiobooks
audiobooks who
knew audiobooks were a thing
here's what happened
the entire time that i kept going
something amazing was happening lisa
they were going to the hardcover but it
wasn't available they bought the only
thing that was available
the audiobook
the five-second rule
became the number one audiobook of the
year lisa
it to this day is the most successful
self-published audio book in the history
of audible
and
it created a brand new partnership that
i have with audible something by the way
that i never
would have had happen
had my hardcover
campaign be successful
and here's the other thing i have never
achieved my goal of being a new york
times selling author and i might never
achieve it
i've never made a traditional bestseller
list
and it proves something that i believe
very deeply and that is that your dreams
and the things that you put on your
vision board have a very important
purpose
they pull you through your fears
they inspire you to take action
but they are not necessarily meant to be
achieved
i believe when you pursue your dreams
and you keep going
and you keep telling yourself that if i
work hard something amazing is going to
happen
you'll achieve something better
something that you don't even know or
can even think about right now
because it's not even on your radar
screen
those dreams are
dots
on the map of your life that pull you in
a direction you're meant to go
but you might never end up there because
you're meant to end up somewhere else
literally
it also when it comes to productivity
and focus and fulfillment it's not when
you get up it's how you get up
and there's all this crazy research like
i'm not some sort of like psycho about
the alarm clock or the snooze button i
personally love sleeping in but i also
know that as somebody that's struggled
with anxiety for
three decades
lying in bed in the morning or at night
is the worst place i can be absolutely
that is where the anxiety can pin you
down like a gravity blanket and so
understanding that the habit of hitting
the snooze button has a detrimental
impact on your productivity all day
because what happens is when you wake up
your brain is typically ready to wake up
when you drift back to sleep after
hitting the snooze button your brain
drifts back into a sleep cycle which
based on research takes about 75 minutes
to complete when the alarm goes off nine
minutes later your brain is now trapped
in a sleep cycle and researchers say it
takes you about four hours to snap out
of what they call sleep inertia
that impacts your productivity all day
long and so you're complaining that i
didn't get enough sleep and you feel
groggy
no you actually got plenty of sleep you
screwed yourself over by hitting the
snooze button and now your prefrontal
cortex can't snap back into operation
until you're ready to go the reticular
activity system the ras for short um for
if you don't know what it is picture a
hair net over your brain that is a live
network and the ras is a filter and it
has a huge job and it is a filter that
blocks out 99
of the world and lets in about you know
point zero zero zero zero zero zero zero
one percent and it is always changing
there are only four things tom that get
through the hair net on your head the
sound of your name and you've
experienced this because you've been
walking through a crowd you're like did
somebody say my name
right this skill party effect cocktail
party effect the second thing that gets
through is any sort of threat so if you
hear a loud noise and you go like this
there are lots of noises you didn't hear
but the loud one you kind of duck
because it's a threat the third thing is
when your partner is interested in sex
with either you or someone else that's
right like why are you checking that
person out right you know because the
brain is letting that information in
the fourth thing and this is where the
transformation
begins
your brain will let in anything that it
believes is important to you the
zygarnic effect is
the documented fact that when something
is important to you and i'll explain
what that means
your brain opens up a checklist in your
mind
and now your brain wants it puts this
item on your checklist it will store the
checklist in your subconscious
it's encoded in your ras
and your mind is now on the alert
to spot things related to it
the way that you make yourself feel like
something is important is your nervous
system goes on alert
while you're thinking about it you're
either super excited about something oh
this is super important or this is the
trauma effect you go on alert and you
have something really bad happen which
is why
things continue to bring it up
throughout the rest of your life so when
you understand that if something's
important to you
your filter will change in real time how
you see the world
you now know how to change your brain to
work for you and looking for hearts is
the way i'm going to prove to you this
happens i want to give you one other
example because everybody's experienced
this if you've ever gone shopping for a
new car or you've dreamt about having a
new car
what happens immediately when you get
excited about that new car is your mind
goes zygon artifact oops okay tom wants
the new bronco that's cool so what do
you see now you see broncos everywhere
now they were always there
but your mind is letting them in
because the zygon art effect
is now mated on a checklist it's changed
the ras
and so i am going to prove to you
that it is
unbelievably cool that you can change
the way that you view the world by
looking for heart-shaped objects
so tomorrow when you wake up you're
going to start your day by high-fiving
yourself in the mirror i want you to
examine what the resistance about
because you're going to start to then un
be able to unpack what's holding you
back
then you're going to go out in the world
just like tell your mind i want to see a
heart today look for a rock look for a
leaf look in your like latte is there a
little shape there is there an oil stain
on the floor and when you see one stop
and go
i i just
like there's a scavenger hunt
i never would have seen that before
thank you brain now your brain's like
more hearts
you will start to see hearts everywhere
and when you can start to train your
brain and realize whoa
this is
actually a cool thing this is
high-fiving your mind when you can see
hearts you can now go wait a minute if i
can change what i see based on what i
tell it
maybe if i got serious about not
constantly saying i'm a failure i
wouldn't attach that or see it
everywhere
maybe if i got serious about saying
i can figure anything out
this is happening for a reason instead
of i'm
you say okay i'm going to learn
something with this
it changes the way your brain filters
everything
and this is such an important piece to
the book because we've all had the
experience where you love somebody
deeply
and you see all their incredible
attributes
and all they see is failure or all they
see is the weight that they can't lose
and it doesn't matter what you say it
doesn't matter what kind of pep talk or
support you give them
your loved one still only sees what they
hate about themselves
blame the filter in your brain you have
been bitching about your appearance or
the weight on your scale the fact that
you're a failure for so long your brain
believes it's important to you to see
reasons why this is true
and one of the things i got to say about
this
and everything in the book is the tools
are simple tom
but it's super important to say
just because you change and start
celebrating yourself it's not going to
make the weight disappear suddenly
it doesn't change the number on the
scale overnight what it changes is you
and that changes your ability
to deal with the problems and the issues
you want to change in your life how does
your favorite sports team begin the game
by high-fiving each other to send
yourself out into the game but when
researchers actually studied nba teams
they could predict who's going to be the
most successful teams at the end of the
season and who's going to be at the
bottom of the league based on one
characteristic at the beginning of the
season in the preseason and that is how
many times does the team in the
preseason do fist bumps high fives or
pats on the back
and what they found is it's the teams
that do that the most in the beginning
have the winningest record and the
reason the question is why well the
reason why is these gestures are more
than gestures they are symbols of trust
and partnership
they build momentum
and so many of us are struggling in life
with people pleasing and guilt and all
of these emotions because we have broken
that partnership with ourselves and this
is a way every morning after brushing
your teeth we're going to stack this
habit put the toothbrush down pick up
your hand look yourself in the mirror
and say how am i going to show up for
that human being today and seal it with
a high five that's it let me explain
what happened so this really interesting
concept called
ghosts in the nursery
and so trauma patterns get automated and
because they're not experienced in your
brain they're felt in your nervous
system
and so it's why you can have a pattern
from your past but be completely unaware
that it's running your life right now
because it's stored not in your
conscious thought but in your nervous
system and you feel it in your body
before it even gets into your head and
so from there's this concept called
ghost in the nursery which basically
means there's all kinds of that goes on
when you're little that you may or may
not remember in your mind but your body
remembers it so for example if you had
parents that were just stressed out
and
they come home and they've been busy and
you're sitting there playing on the
floor and there's there's toys
everywhere and mom or dad's reaction to
a mess is to scream
that creates this kind of thing in your
nervous system now you may not remember
that episode that happened on may 17
1972
but your nervous system remembers what
it's like
so fast forward you're now 51 years old
and
you walk in the house and there's a mess
everywhere and even though you have said
i'm not going to bulldoze and yell at
anybody
my
body recognizes the situation
so what do you do you repeat the pattern
you saw
and so what i'm working on right now is
a pattern that is encoded in my nervous
system
i was trying to create a video yes or
two days ago
um for share the mic for share the mic
now i'm trying to create a video and i'm
like doing take after take because i
want to get it right
and my daughter comes waltzing into the
room and was like
how long are you going to be doing this
and i was like
can't you say it
i literally like screamed at her and she
looked at me louis
and she goes
you have a real problem wow how's your
daughter
20.
and i said i i calmly said you're right
i do
when i get interrupted
i
lose control of the response and i'm
working so
hard and the way that you and i'm not
clearly not mastering this yet
but the way that you do it is as you
feel it rise up
you have to you know you can use the
five second rule five four three two one
you can use just take a quick breath
you can notice the pattern and you've
got to create a pause between the
emotion rising up and the reaction that
gets automated and for many people the
reaction loses to run away
it's to leave the room it's to avoid the
confrontation the it was just easy you
know hold on let me let the clock go
even though you you hate being
interrupted by anything this is a great
interview i did like i didn't do i
didn't do the bulldozer i was i was calm
because i wasn't a human being i'm only
mean to human beings um i know like i a
lot of people run away they avoid
conflict they say it's just easier
but if running away and avoiding
conflict
continues to create a pattern where you
feel invisible and your boundaries are
trumped on that's a pattern and you know
here's the other thing about patterns
running away
and being quiet might have saved you
when you were little
because if you were quiet and out of the
room you didn't get hit you didn't get
yelled at you were out of harm's way
so when you were little it was a genius
pattern because it protected you but the
issue for adults is that again we walk
around
with the patterns that we created when
we were eight years old in different
situations than we are in now and now we
are
completely a robot to these patterns
jealousy is one of the most powerful
directional signals on the planet
because you're only jealous of people
that are doing things or have things
that you actually want it's impossible
to be fake jealous whatever you're
jealous of is hitting something deeply
personal
pay attention to it instead of stewing
in it go oh
flip it
that's interesting
i wonder why i'm jealous
what is it about it oh
it's that they're doing it consistently
it's that they've built a team it's that
they've aligned their work together so
that they're spending more time together
how could i take those things that i'm
really now really inspired by
and take action and go get them in my
life
because the thing about jealousy is it's
just your inspiration that's blocked
jealousy is sort of the insecurity
that you have that blocks this
inspiration i guarantee you back to the
uber driver he's jealous of all the
other actors earning oscars
because he's so inspired by the thought
of doing that in his own life but his
insecurity is blocking action his fear
is blocking action so instead of it
being inspiration
it shows up as jealousy and i'm here to
tell you the second you feel jealousy
freaking
stop okay
let's unpack that what exactly is it
about it and now if i were inspired by
it because there's enough success to go
around for everybody
if i can use that as a road map to then
go figure out how i might be able to do
that for myself
wow
talk about a game changer and now let's
add in the high five what if every time
i took a little step i celebrated myself
for just doing it now you're building
small wins and momentum in a direction
that's meant for you that's how you
change your life we encourage people to
break boundaries you know they feel like
they're limited
but
you talk about uh your boundaries are
there to serve you so obviously it's a
different type of boundary but
you know yeah so so here's the thing
what boundaries do you need to help
yourself to protect yourself and which
ones do you need to grow past that are
holding you back
i think that the definition with
boundaries that has helped me the most
is understanding the boundaries are for
me they're not for you
and the single biggest mistake that we
make in any relationship particularly
romantic ones but also work related ones
is we do not express what we need any
pattern can be replaced
change isn't personal it just feels
personal change is just about
identifying patterns and replacing them
with new ones that's it
and it'll take a little while because
they're encoded in your nervous system
and your default is to just do it
yourself
um but you have to you cannot as a rule
punish other people for you didn't
communicate right so i'll give you the
perfect example so chris and i have been
married for 24 years
and when i was before the talk show and
i made my living mostly by uh you know
doing 100 speeches a year
i would be on the road 150 days a year
and
when i would come home there was always
something that pissed me off
like what like ah the trash is taken out
the clothes are here or is it something
else oh no i'm way worse than that are
you kidding
i would walk in after being gone for
five or six days
and there
on the island in the kitchen
was a vase
that had dead flowers
the ones that i had bought for myself a
week before and it was as if everybody
in my family had been walking around the
island for six days as if there was some
dead flower sculpture in the middle of
the island and so i would come home
and
first of all the only person that's
really excited to see me is a dog and my
family did sit me down at one point they
said you know you realize when you're
not here we have our own lives so you
don't put your lives on hold while you
know for us and we're not putting our
lives on hold so it's not that we're not
excited to see you but we're not
organizing our whole lives around when
mom comes home right to be like the dog
to be like the dog excited and running
up and jumping in your arms and kissing
you yeah
yeah no no
but that but i think that's cool because
that means
that they're independent and doing their
own thing they've set boundaries
they've set boundaries with me perfect
so
for probably six months i would get
pissy and i would walk in and put my
bags down and i grabbed the flowers and
i demonstratedly how many times has
everyone done this throw them out loudly
like everyone hears you communication
yeah i'm getting my communication just
throwing these dead flowers out
communicate to you that you should buy
me flowers like i'm not saying that but
that's what the body language is right
how dare i have been off i've been in
four cities and then you become a mar
like uh i'm disgusting when i tell the
story but this is it this is like
so well i see you've got some lovely
flowers behind you that look alive so
that's good to see oh there's nice
so
i do love flowers so finally
i just said to chris
you know what would make me feel
amazing
is if
when i came home
you had
just bought some flowers just go to the
just when you're at the grocery store it
doesn't you don't have to order like i'm
saying by the five dollar pack of half
dead tulips just something okay
and and then he said why
and this is the most important part of
expressing and look you don't have to
give an explanation if you're trying to
like cut off a toxic person but if you
want to express
boundaries with somebody
because you want them to understand you
more deeply give them the why i said
because it makes me think
that you are excited for me to come home
and that you knew i was coming
because i'm starting to feel forgotten
so underneath the anger louis
wow
was hurt
and feeling like i didn't matter
and so i'll be darned i walk in
and
um
there they are and i literally feel
so seen
what are the key principles
of how someone deals with themselves
when they love themselves when they care
for themselves what are those key tenets
those those key values that we can draw
ourselves to and measure against and say
am i doing that for myself i think at
the heart of it are two foundational
habits that you need and one you already
mentioned
it's being kind to yourself
it's really that simple and i know you
know the study that they did in the uk
where they looked at every possible
behavior change that you could do in
life
and
whether it was changing in diet
meditation exercise relationship changes
all of it
the one change that has the biggest
impact on fulfillment and happiness is
being kind to yourself and it's the one
change we practice the least because i
don't think we know how yeah i don't how
do yeah how do we be contest well number
one stop the beat down in the mirror and
despite the fact that it might feel
weird or you're gonna resist it or you
got a lot of dust oh boy we gotta wipe
it away
oh it's more like mud it's not like dust
jay has dust the rest of us are caked
with mud gotta get some elmo grease in
there uh the high five habit every day
is wiping that away okay that's number
one number two
when you catch yourself
in the what if loop
or the beat down use the five second
rule count backwards five four three two
one interrupt it and start just
interrupting it
because you don't have to listen to it
you can't always control when it pops up
but you can start to create distance
from it meditation obviously helps with
that but in terms of the hand to fist
combat with your own brain
i prefer punch back 54321 and then i
literally go i'm not thinking about that
another strategy that you can use as
you're doing the hand-to-hand combat
with your own brain
is
come up with like an avatar
for this
negative voice okay and make it really
good like when our son was really
profoundly struggling with anxiety he's
16 now he started to call that worrywart
in his head that was beating him up
oliver and he looked like this big
pimply bully of a kid that was out of
the diary the wimpy kid and he would
literally say when he was nine years old
shut up oliver like you're not invited
to sleep like he would literally talk to
it and it sounds like you're giving your
kid multiple personalities that's not
actually what's happening you're
leveraging objectivity so you separate
yourself from the voice that's talking
to you yes um another thing that you can
do i love this for worrying oh this is a
genius to steal your word uh move when
you catch yourself doing the what ifs
because we know there's two forms of
worrying right there's the type of
worrying that just destroys you that's
destructive worrying where you just
ruminate what if what if what if then
there's the positive form of worrying
which is productive because it it
motivates you to change when you get
stuck in the what if what if what if
interrupt it with this 54321 and then go
what if it all works out
what if this turns out to be one of the
hardest things i do but the best
decision i've ever made
what if placing a bet on myself
was the moment my life changed
what if it all works out
because you can't argue with that and it
literally stops
that sort of cycling because worrying is
just a habit that you have it's like a
pathway that you've plowed in your mind
and it's a protection mechanism
you're actually not a procrastinator
you're not a worrier you're just afraid
yeah and by staying in your mind you
think you're safe
and really what you're doing is you're
holding yourself back from living the
life that you're meant to live
i love that that's such a great answer
so that's because i've got a couple of
yeah be kind to yourself and then
there's another one and then the other
ones keep the little promises that you
make to yourself
and there's two simple ways you can
practice this that everybody's gonna
hate
when you set the alarm the night before
i don't believe in having the same
wake-up time every morning
because i think if you have a normal
life
things are constantly changing
and so i think if you were to have one
simple habit which is the night before
you go to bed think about when you need
to wake up to truly support yourself
and then intentionally set your alarm
and if you want to get really
intentional with the science here make
it like a random odd number don't make
it six o'clock make it 6 17
because there's a purpose behind that
and then when that alarm rings don't
think about it like an obligation
i want you to think about it like it's a
promise that you're going to practice
keeping
and this is where you can use the five
second rule you're just going to count
backwards five four three two one to
interrupt all of the desire in your mind
and body to stay in bed or to hit the
snooze button or to argue against what
you need to do and you're going to push
through that resistance and take action
and by getting out of bed simply when
you said you would
you are again behavioral activation
therapy you're acting like a person who
keeps their promises you talk a lot
about taking responsibility for that
recognizing nobody's coming to save you
something you said in the book it's
something that you've said in interviews
it's something that i absolutely think
is really powerful
how do we use that why is that important
to recognize
well it's important to recognize because
first of all nobody is coming
i mean if you've been sitting around
waiting for somebody to discover you to
pick you to save you to rescue to give
you your shot it's not happening
like at some point you got to wake up
and realize when you're 18 and you're
out of that house
you have to parent yourself
your life is your responsibility and as
a woman one of the things that i found
to be
extraordinarily transformational is when
i stopped in a very traditional sense
looking to my partner to be responsible
for providing
for me
providing financially providing the
support providing when i realized
wait a minute it starts with me
i have to be
able to figure out how to make myself
happy
that's by the way the secret to a happy
relationship marry somebody who's happy
and work on your own happiness preach
and so when you stop outsourcing
your happiness your validation your
support all of it and you bring it back
in
and you get responsible for it it sounds
scary it's so
liberating because you could do anything
when you're responsible when you're the
driver of your life when you're not
looking out to anybody else to fix it
for you can you ask for help of course
but the buck stops with you
you're the one that has to do the work
you're the one who has to push your own
ass you're the one who has to figure out
what makes you happy you're the one who
has to figure out and become self-aware
about what you need and then you're the
one that has to
find whatever it is the courage or being
humble enough to ask for help
even if it's asking for help
from the biggest ally that you have
which is the person staring back at you
in the mirror every damn morning if you
google word wheel or wheel of emotions
you will find that um if you ask
somebody name as many emotions as you
can most people can name three happy sad
angry
there's literally like 113 of them
from disgusted to
hopeless to
and if you if you start with a cor this
thing allows you to start with a core
emotion and go out
because back to the flower example i was
expressing anger
that's not what i was feeling
i was feeling invisible and forgotten
and so the word wheel
is something that we used several times
a week to help people go from the thing
that they are expressing to
communicating what you're feeling which
is a lot like the work that you wrote
about in your book yeah around wearing
masks yeah getting to the root of the
core emotion you're feeling but not
expressing
oh i can't wait don't stop touching your
eyes i can't open my eyes anymore okay
don't open your eyes don't open your
eyes
is
[Music]
refresh your routine why is this
important i'll tell you why that's this
is important because there is so much
science that talks about the power of
your morning routine and there's also so
much noise out there about the morning
routine and i don't know about you but
when i read all these articles about the
power of a morning routine i'm typically
reading them by some male influencer who
clearly doesn't have children yet or
some male ceo no no offense to the dudes
but all of the articles out there tend
to be written by guys that have
two and a half hours before work starts
to somehow drink mushroom tea and
meditate and go to yoga and exercise and
drink bulletproof coffee and sit in an
infrared sauna and i don't know what
planet these people live on but they
clearly don't have children or a job
they need to get to at eight o'clock in
the morning and not to make anyone wrong
i'm being realistic i'm being realistic
about the fact that you need a morning
routine but you need one that works for
you
and for where you are in your life in
this season you see i had a morning
routine that used to take me 30 to 40
minutes
last year when i had more time i've had
a morning routine that took an hour when
i had time and the ability to go for a
jog in the morning i'd incorporate that
in the morning routine do you realize
that my morning routine right now
has been responsible for helping me curb
my anxiety it's responsible for why i'm
so successful and i'm able to be
productive my morning routine 10 minutes
long that's it it's 10 minutes long
because that's what works for me in this
season of my life anyone that's going
through some really
confronting stuff in their personal life
that's me right now don't really
feel ready to discuss any of the details
but it is a very challenging moment
right now for me
and the waves of emotion
all of them are coming and going
right now in my life
and
i want to share something that i am
finding helpful
as i move through this um
really
[Music]
tough moment in time
i remind myself that these feelings are
temporary
number one
and that helps me
find strength and knowing that i'm gonna
learn something in this moment i'm gonna
ride through this pain
and i'm gonna come out stronger and i
won't always feel like that like i do
right now
the second thing is um
i try not to attach myself to the waves
that are coming of
sadness and anger and fear and
frustration and
[Music]
just all of it and uh
by that i mean i let the wave
of emotion come into my body
i try not to hold on to it grip it
attach it i feel what i need to feel
and i breathe it out
that's number two
and number three a lot of journaling
a lot of journaling just
pouring out everything i'm feeling as a
way to excavate it responsibly anyway i
wanted to make this video because i know
you're probably going through something
i know you're probably experiencing
waves of emotion frustration sadness
anger joy whatever it may be you're
human
this is a human experience to feel
emotional waves and so remind yourself
whether it's a high or a low it's
temporary
you can get through this
breathe through the wave don't attach
yourself to it and let it knock you
over and
three just dump everything you're
feeling out into a journal
instead of at other people and that will
help you
process the emotions you need to process
because you don't want to shove them
down it will help you get clear about
where you want to go
next
and
what you're meant to learn in this
moment and it will help you move through
it with grace with strength with
resilience how do we start to heal
trauma within our body
excellent question so uh we did a whole
uh project for audible original
um
called take control that was all about
the thesis was this any area of your
life that you're stuck
i am willing to bet everything i have
that you have
a trauma pattern from your past
that you've never healed
um you've got a boss that is abusive
guarantee you this has to do with a
trauma pattern from your past you can't
succeed in the areas you want you can't
lose the weight there's some pattern
from your past so the first thing is
recognizing that you actually experience
trauma
and i am a huge proponent as so many
people are of widening the definition
because i think up until about five
years ago most of us thought that trauma
just meant okay you uh were in active
duty
or you were in a huge accident or
incident that was highly traumatic or
you survived some sort of uh physical
sexual whatever abuse trauma
is just about any kind of experience
that you witness or you absorb that has
your nervous system
light up on edge and start warning you
so if you've ever had like you could
have a critical parent and you just
brace for them
you could have a parent that that drinks
like crazy and you brace at five o'clock
because you know they're coming home you
could have been abandoned by a parent or
have a parent that was mentally ill or
have a parent that was so on your ass
because they wanted you to be a pro
football player and so you are
constantly on edge it's when your
nervous system fires up to a state of
alert
that
now gets programmed into your body as a
response
there's a reason why so many couples
at five o'clock at night start bickering
and it has to do with the fact that at
five o'clock is typically when a lot of
parents 20 years ago were coming home
from work and that's when the arguing
would start
and so what happens when you witness
that or you feel it is as a kid you're
now in a state where you're on edge i
see you rocking in your chair i actually
have an incredible quote of yours about
dreams you say when it comes to your
dreams you have two choices pursue them
or be haunted by them
it's true you can't forget a dream
you can
something that you want in your life
once you really want it and you give
yourself permission to feel that desire
there's something called the zygarnic
effect
and the zygarnic effect is this thing
that happens in your brain and i also
think it's tied into your heart your
nervous system but it happens in your
brain where
when something is important to you
and you can feel that wave hit you
your mind takes note and goes oh
i'm going to put this on the list in the
file of my mind called this is important
and whenever you are near anything
that's related to what's important to
you
your mind changes the live network and
filter of your brain will change in real
time to try to alert you
to the fact that you're near something
that is important to you and i'm not
making this up this has been proven in
study after study
and
i think that's why your dreams haunt you
you can ignore them you can shove them
down you can tell yourself you don't
want it anymore
but if you've ever wanted something
deeply it doesn't leave you it gets
stored in the subconscious part of your
mind waiting for you to remember that
it's there and to get to work on it if
you've always dreamt of living in an
amazing beach house somewhere
you you will
always think about it
and you'll either pursue it or you're
going to be haunted by it
if you've ever thought about taking your
grandmother's recipe
and
like doing something with that tomato
sauce
you'll either pursue it or it's going to
haunt you
and that's because of how you're
designed as a human being
so you got two choices
you either do something about it
or you're going to live for the rest of
your life with this thing in the back of
your mind that slowly
eats at you
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag
believe down in the comments below on
this video i will showcase you and
celebrate you somewhere on the screen in
a future video because
you are awesome if you want more top 10
videos they're not on this channel
anymore i have a dedicated channel just
for it go check it out the link is right
there next to me continue to believe and
i'll see you there